Just before we get into today's video. Let me thank today's sponsors.
Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community for creators,
with thousands of classes in design business, and more.
We've talked about skill Gere a few times on this channel and mentioned various
courses and things you can learn on that platform,
but maybe you haven't gone Skillshare yet, and you were totally skinless.
That's a great shame because there are thousands of classes on Skillshare for
you to level up your design, your business, your video, your social media,
whatever skills as you want to improve,
or just take them from nothing to something. You can.
Do that too. At.
The time, when so many important conversations are happening in our world,
your voice is more essential than ever explore classes to unlock your creativity
for social good here and visual politics. We've taken video production courses,
camera courses, loads of YouTube stuff.
And we also want to squeeze as much out of our day as possible.
So we watched this course by a guy called Thomas Frank,
who is also a YouTuber on getting more stuff done in a day.
It's great stuff and worth checking out if you want to be more productive.
So yes, Skillshare just go do it. You'll like it.
It's also free for two months,
so you can try it out and I'm pretty sure you'll continue your membership
because it is so great support, visual politic by supporting Skillshare.
For a limited time,
use the link in the description to get a free trial of Skillshare premium
membership.
We warn you that this video may hurt your sensibilities and cause you a strong
sense of indignation. And it's.
We are going to talk about the Royal house with possibly the most reprehensible
and despotic behavior in the entire world.
Saturn Royals from my country's own reprehensible behavior, not withstanding.
We are going to tell you,
I have a Salton has turned these people into a kind of cash cow that he milks
relentlessly. Are you ready? So let's get started.
Can you to think of a country in Southeast Asia, other than Singapore,
and that has a GDP per capita, similar to that to Spain or South Korea?
What country would you think of? I'll give you a few seconds. Three, two, one,
any ideas I'm sure. Very few of you would have thought of Brunei that says,
if you haven't already read the title of this video,
which admittedly is a little bit of a giveaway,
and it's very unlikely that the vast majority of you have heard of the small
country nestled on the Island of Borneo and surrounded by territories belonging
to the Malaysian Federation after all.
It's not only small in terms of territory, but also in population.
The country officially known as the state of Brunei.
Doris alum has barely half a million and a half,
Despite not being well known.
We are talking about one of the countries with the highest wealth per capita
ratios in the world. It's oil and gas reserves are relatively huge.
And Salton has an Al bulkier has been able to take advantage of oil and
liquified natural gas,
which they also process generate more than half of the nation's GDP.
What's more,
most of these resources are extracted from its exclusive economic zone at sea
giving Brunei.
One of the best preserved natural environments on the face of the.
Wow, so far.
Thanks. So pretty good. Right? But hold.
On just one moment,
because you already know that all that glitters is not gold and this couldn't be
more true than in the case of Bruno.
Right?
Swiping such a wealthy country.
The reality is that Bruneians millions for new Orleans Bruneians they enjoy a
fairly average standard of living.
The thing is though national bank balance is a site.
If we're talking about freedoms or human rights,
it's not just that this Asian countries track record is poor,
is that it keeps getting worse. But having said that,
I'm sure you already have a few questions.
Questions like F this alternate is apparently so rich.
What happens to all the money that Brunei citizens just don't see what's
happening politically in the country.
So that's unlike most of the rest of the world.
Civil rights and freedoms are actually in decline. Well,
my visual quality goes and there's a video.
We are going to answer those two questions.
And we are going to tell you some things about the most extreme eccentricities
and the most totalitarian leanings of the current Sultan. Are you ready?
So let's go to Brunei, but not really because their human rights are appalling.
The wasteful sultanates.
And to see next as a story that seems to be taken entirely from a Hollywood
movie, you know, it's one of those stories of mega wealthy sell tons.
There's a random sales with the most extravagant luxuries you can possibly
imagine and who even have a harem of women all to themselves, you know,
like Hollywood movies or that dream I had last night. Well,
that's not too far off of what the current Royal house of Brunei has become a
Royal house that not only likes to own things, but also likes to flaunt them.
Take, for example,
the 14 million gold rolls Royce limousine owned by CELTA and has Hassanah.
I know don't think that's the only expensive car he keeps in his garage,
not by a long shot. In fact,
it is estimated that the Royal house has more than 7,000 vehicles at his
disposal.
We are talking about a fleet with an estimated value of around wait for it's
$5 billion in cars alone. That's right.
$5 billion.
A beat.
Of course we are talking about assault on whose wealth is estimated to be more
than a $20 billion to give you an idea that figure is much,
much higher than the entire gross domestic product of the entire country.
In fact,
if we take into account that the country's GDP is around about 13.5 billion,
this means that the assault on fortune is almost 50% greater to give you an
example of what that's like. That would be equivalent to, I don't know,
the British Royal family managing a wealth of almost $4 trillion with a
T that's more than the entire GDP of Germany. And that is nuts.
The fact is that among the immense in Venturi,
that makes up the cell towns assets, we can find a 10 luxury yachts,
at least 17 airplanes have more than 150 mansions and 12 different countries.
And that is not all as if these assets were not enough of a display of
ostentatious and luxury.
This self-tan lives in the largest private palace in the world,
a policy that has no than 1,788 rooms, 257 bathrooms,
five swimming pools,
it's own private mosque and a garage for 110 of its thousands of cars along with
many other features. For example,
the entire pilot is lined with 38 types of Italian, marble Shanghai,
granted English, crystals, and Indian silk decorations. In other words,
we are talking about a guy who does not skimp when it comes to luxury to
illustrate this during his wildest days, when he was just a little younger,
it's estimated that the Salton spent almost $750,000 a day for 10.
Of course.
It's not all about flashing the luxury goods.
The Sultan also has his business side. For example,
he even has his own hotel chain. Well, technically the chain,
the Dorchester collection is owned by the country's sovereign fund.
A fund that in turn depends on the ministry of finance,
which surprise surprise is run by self-tan has an ally himself.
Let's just say the end night,
there is basically no difference between the public patrimony and the patrimony
of the Royal house, or rather the, in this alternate,
the public patrimony belongs to the Royal house.
Of course.
All this immense fortune is not only enjoyed by the Sultan,
but also by his entire family who, by the way,
don't hold back and exhibiting that wealth on social media networks. In fact,
his 10th child is quite the Instagram star with more than 2 million followers on
Instagram, young team at just 29 years old.
It doesn't hold back and showing his helicopter flights,
his parachute drops his yachting, his love of polo,
or his travels around the world by private jet.
And if I sound a little better that's because I am I'd hardly have any Instagram
followers. If you want to follow me at the grantee graced,
please do I create validation? How does that,
that you've got to hand this to them because these are clearly productive
people. They're more than productive. They're super productive. I mean,
think of all the things they managed to pack into their days. Well,
I'm here just recording.
How to use, but as you.
Know, visual politics is not a celebrity gossip shoe.
If we tell you all these things,
it's simply to get ourselves a little better situated because keep one thing in
mind, Brunei is not just any country and neither is the Sultan.
Just any Sultan
Personnel is considered one of the last absolute monarchs of the 21st century.
And it's the second longest ruling Monarch a past only by the queen of England
who we all know, we'll never know
The more precise he has been on the throne since 1967.
And take note because he is not only the Sultan.
He also holds the possessions of prime minister,
minister of defense minister of finance and minister of foreign affairs.
And who knows maybe during the making of this video,
he's put himself in charge of yet another ministry like the ministry of polo or
yachting or having too many cards. So yeah,
the government is basically just heavy.
Can you imagine a meeting of the executive?
It's basically one of those houses of mirrors that you get in the circus,
unless you see between the ministry of defense,
the ministry of finance and the ministry of foreign affairs.
There will always be a consensus because it is pretty difficult not to agree
with yourself. The minister's council sessions must be pretty boring and short.
This is an example of what absolute power looks like. Now at this point,
I'm sure many of you were thinking, okay,
this man must be the typical desk bot who rules in dollar bills at night while
there's people starved. Right? Well, the truth has no, not really.
At least not completely.
Wheatley.
Not make system developed in Brunei is anything but typical Brunei is the
textbook definition of a rentier welfare state.
But let me explain the Royal house of Brunei buys the loyalty and silence of the
people and exchange for certain services, which are of course,
trifles compared to the potential wealth,
but it citizens should enjoy considering the immense riches of the country.
So how do they get away with it? Well, let's take a look
Because basically the Brunei government uses a small parts of its oil and gas
revenues to ensure that it's 460,000 inhabitants do not lack the basics and the
rest they keep for themselves.
And this way they can continue to live like gods without risking that the people
will rebel against them due to hunger or poverty,
or even questioned the unethical behaviors of their leaders.
So basically what they do is they throw the citizens, a few parents,
some crumbs from the table, if you will. And they also rule with an iron fist,
because if there is one thing that is expressly for bed and above all others and
Brunei does speaking ill of the royalty.
Emily.
Careful though, because when we say that Brunei citizens receive the basics,
we mean a house and a car,
both of which are subsidized with Lewins at very low rates,
but also receive free health care and dental care,
free education and old age pensions,
even funerals are subsidized by the government. Of course,
don't be fooled by thinking that the health and education are high quality.
The government keeps a tight purse. It's a question of incentives.
The more money you have left over, the more money goes into your pocket.
I mean.
To be fair, this description may not be technically accurate, but in practice,
this is pretty much how things work in Brunei.
We are talking about a country and what citizens have become highly dependent on
state revenues and therefore on whatever the cell tan wants to give them.
But standard of living is nowhere near that of developed countries.
And as the saying goes, there is no such thing as a free lunch.
And in Berneice case, the trade-off is freedom,
human rights and social mobility.
Unless of course you happen to have the good fortune to be born into the
wealthier upper classes that maintain close ties,
very close ties with the Royal house.
And that is what explains headlines like this found in 2019.
This new penal code would enshrine quote, cruel and inhumane punishments,
UN rights, chief warns, United nations news. So.
What on earth is happening now with politics and Brunei? So the,
even the UN itself,
which typically looks the other way in political issues is jumping up and down
and sending all the alarms. What are the evils that are so serious?
The Sultan eight has decided to punish them and accrue an inhumane way. Well,
let's see.
Islamism, vice and hypocrisy Brunei.
The Muslim majority country,
approximately three out of every four and hot buttons are Muslim.
The rest are a mixture of Christian, Buddhist and indigenous beliefs.
But despite the fact that one in four people is not Muslim since 2014,
the country has introduced reforms and punishments from Islamic law,
the Sharia to his penal code.
It was an idea that came to Sultan Hassanah at the end of the nineties.
And that most of us citizens kind of didn't think it was all that bad.
Although seeing how things work here,
it looks like their opinion wouldn't have mattered, basically a tall.
So my friends, do you want to know more about evil ideas? Well, if so,
then hold on to your seat
Because the reforms that began to be implemented in 2014 were completed in
April, 2019. They stipulate for example,
the consensual sexual relations between men carry the death penalty by stoning.
Those between women are punishable by up to 40 lashes with a stick or 10 years
in prison.
And amputation of limbs has been imposed for themes starting with the right hand
and continuing with the left foot. If they re-offend. In other words, in 2019,
the Sultan of Brunei completed what most of the stretch establishment of Sharia
law throughout the entire country and an environment in which no neighboring
Muslim country, as established capital penalties for this type of.
Behavior.
This way,
Brunei has become the only country in Southeast Asia to impose a strict version
of Islamic law in the style of Afghanistan, Saudi Arabia.
Right?
Of course,
to date Brunei has not yet applied the death penalty for any of these cases.
And in fact has not executed anyone since 1957 when the country was still a
British protectorate. But the fact that they have added Shari,
a lot of the penal code sends out a dangerous warning.
The power of the Sultan is above all else,
and he will continue to be the guarantor of the purity of Islam and the
application of its law in the most fundamentalist version possible.
But hold on just one moment, because given all of these rules,
I'm sure many of you are thinking, okay,
if the salt mine is so devoted to Islam,
then he should also live as the Islamic tradition and rules dictate, right?
Well, it will come as a surprise to none of you. That's new,
not really in finance. He seems to do quite the opposite,
a religious figure being hyper-critical surely not.
It's not only because there's luxurious way of life and his flaunted wealth run
contrary to the humility that Islam promulgates,
but also because of his personal behavior,
you see both Al and his brother Jeffrey have a lifestyle. That's a bet.
How can we put this controversial as controversial as it has notorious
throughout the world. For example,
there are many women who have claimed to have been part of a kind of personal
harem of the Sultan's brother with dozens of them housed within the palace
compound itself and semi confined.
But that being able to communicate with the outside world at all,
these are women who on many occasions also surprise, surprise,
had relations with the Sultan himself. In fact, Jillian Lauren,
one of the former Hiram girls tells of her experience in her book,
some girls where she recounts,
how her life was in these parts and how the girls were used and discarded at
well, listen.
I have more money than anyone else. I know that they both,
the Salton and Jeffrey had been married and divorced multiple times.
It's really hypocritical, Jillian Lauren.
And of course, she's right. Well,
the Sultan of Brunei also imposes the death penalty by stoning for adultery.
He and his brother had been running wild parties with dozens,
hundreds of Western women for years. In fact, another woman,
Shannon [inaudible] Mr. United States in 1992, don't, you know,
she went so far as to the nice, the Sultan in a court in the United States,
which eventually dismissed the complaint. Juju has immunity as a head of state,
however, the case did to help to make her story famous and what she related,
for example, that she accepted a job in Brunei for $3,000 a day.
The ended up being as a sort of Sammy slave for the Sultan's brother Jeffrey,
and for the Sultan himself.
It is a great pleasure to welcome my good friend, his majesty, the salt.
But don't think for one second,
but these two characters are the only party goers involved in scandals scandals
that almost always end with, let's say an unethical waste of money.
Another brother of the self-tan Mohammed bulkier,
who allegedly detested Hasson Allen Jeffrey's wastefulness received a settlement
of $2 billion.
No questions asked when he sees to be minister of foreign affairs and trades in
2015. But I mean, who's not going to shell the disgust for $2 billion,
but just remember though, he really hates waste.
The fact is that the opulence of the Royal family and their behavior,
which is totally opposed to the teachings of Islam,
make them probably one of the most hypocritical governments on the international
stage today. And think about what kind of a statement that is.
But not only that, if we add the social stagnation due to the countries,
rent to your model, the lack of freedoms,
the breaches of basic human rights and a Royal family base and wealth,
vice and hypocrisy. What we end up with is modern Brunei,
but now it's over to you.
What do you think of this curious system whereby Libertas idle laws are applied
to citizens, but not to royalty Wilburn,
I'll be able to move forward while such a large part of its hydrocarbon revenue
goes directly to the Royal household.
And will I ever get more followers on Instagram?
So we really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit a Lake if you did.
And don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
You had the little alarm button down there. You'll get updates.
Whenever we release new content, don't forget to check out our friends,
as well as the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that we're not my dulcet tones.
And I like that kind of thing. You can check out my podcast,
it's called making your friends again,
and it's available wherever you get your podcasts. Also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion on our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you next time.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.